c'est vraiment une interpellation sur
lequel les forces de police et de
gendarmerie de martinique était
totalement mobilisé depuis déjà de
nombreuses semaines
là en l'occurrence c'est certes un
travail tout à fait remarquable un
travail extrêmement minutieux un travail
sans relâche des effectifs de la
direction interrégionale de la police
judiciaire ici en martinique qui a
permis cette interpellation avec le
concours essentiel déterminant de
l'antenne du gign sans laquelle cette
intervention n'aurait pu intervenir dans
de telles conditions puisque encore une
fois c'est une interpellation qui est
plus qui s'est réalisé sans incidents
alors ce que je vous indiquais c'est que
c'est une l'intéressé était recherché
dans le cadre de l'homicide volontaire
qui a qui est survenu le 26 juillet
dernier devant l'établissement de nuit
le maximus en l'occurrence donc il
appartiendra maintenant à cette mesure
de garde à vue qui ré qui est menée sous
l'égide d'un juge d'instruction ici à
fort-de-france de déterminer quel était
son application exact dans le cadre de
ces faits d'autres personnes ont aussi
interpellé et était avec ce monsieur
on était aussi interpeller d'autres
personnes également recherché dans le
cadre de dossiers distincts ont été
interpellés ce matin à 6 heures